Speaker 1: As we wait to find out whether
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis will or won't
throw his hat into the ring to try to
be the Republican presidential nominee,
I want to go through the most likely reasons why
Donald Trump's 2024 run could be a complete and
total disaster. Now, before we jump into the
reasons, remember that since his announcement,
which was really low energy, people trying to
walk out of the ballroom at Mar a Lago as the
announcement was still going on, one of the lowest
energy presidential announcements I've ever seen.
Trump has barely left his house for the month
since the announcement. Everything that's going
on is strange. New polling is very bad for Trump,
and we'll talk about that in a moment. So that's
sort of like the preface. But I also want to add
to the preface, no matter what I say here, we're
not counting Trump out. He shouldn't be counted
out. This was a mistake that was made in 2016.
We still don't know what's going to happen, as Joe
Walsh told us yesterday. For now, Trump is still
at the top of the party. However, there are things
that are different this time around. We have a
former president who lost and is now running again
after not being president for four years. Those
are not common circumstances. In addition, that
former president who's running again is losing in
early polling to a guy who hasn't even announced
that he's running for anything. Ron DeSantis So
this is really an unprecedented situation. Now I
get emails from people saying, David, I generally
am hearing, Oh, this could be bad for Trump,
this could go bad. What are the most present,
I guess I would say risks of how this could
go poorly. Okay, let's go through them in no
particular order. Number one, Trump might, and it
appears that he will face significant opposition
from within the Republican Party. Some Republicans
see Trump's candidacy as we like the policy. I
know. That's hilarious. It's like, what policy?
We like the policy. But Trump is divisive. Trump
is damaging to the Republican Party's chances of
winning. We don't think he can win. And this is
part of what former Republican Congressman Joe
Walsh told us yesterday. They like Trump ism,
but they just don't know that Trump could win.
They're just not sure about it. So that's number
one. And the early signs from the polling we're
in, Ron DeSantis is already beating Trump in many
polls, even though he hasn't announced is a sign
that indeed there may be significant dissent from
within the Republican Party. Number two, I know
that we always say this and it never happens.
Trump does anything he wants and then still, you
know, becomes president. Whatever Trump's past
conduct, including this sort of culmination of
multiple impeachments inciting the insurrection
at the U.S. Capitol, etc., may acutely weaken
him and make him vulnerable to attacks from
others from within and outside of his party. In a
way that was not the case during prior elections
because in 2016 was before the insurrection
and 2020 was before the insurrection. We don't
know to what degree that is going to impact the
campaign and how it will affect Donald Trump.
Three Trump's statements and policies and
inflammatory rhetoric, immigration, Mexicans,
the anti Semitic stuff. Now it's conceivable
that it will alienate not the MAGA base,
but the types of folks that are more in the
middle. The independents, the. I'm a Republican,
but I don't love Trump. But I'd probably vote
for him. Except maybe now it's just gotten beyond
the pale. We know that there's anti-Semitism and
xenophobia and racism in the Republican Party, but
it's not complete and total. And that may impact
Trump if Trump decides to go full steam. Full
steam ahead on that in his 2024 run. And he seems
like maybe he has the rhetoric that he has been
focusing on at rallies when he was still having
them was anti-trans, anti-immigrant, ridiculing
people from all sorts of different walks of
life. So that is something that could have an
impact. Legal challenges. This is another layer
to this. Trump may well get indicted. There are
ongoing investigations into financial dealings.
There's the possibility of criminal charges.
There are civil suits. All of this stuff could,
number one, be a distraction from the campaign.
But maybe more importantly, it really could
undermine his credibility as a candidate.
How is a Republican electorate that already
seems to have cooled on Trump going to react
if the guy is under indictment and being
prosecuted? Are they're going to say, well,
we should go to somebody less controversial
with fewer encumbrances? Or is it going to
activate them and get them to say they're going to
indict my president? I'll show them by supporting
Trump. It's unpredictable. It's an open question.
I don't think we'll know if and until it happens.
And then there's. The financial aspect to this.
Trump has drifted donors for a very long time,
but he may struggle to fundraise. He may have
real problems fundraising from certain donors,
particularly donors who would be hesitant to
contribute to Trump because of the potential
legal problems of people unwilling to contribute
to Trump because they'd prefer someone else like
a DeSantis and just want to wait to see Does
DeSantis say he's going to run and that could
weaken Trump early. So it is very difficult
to predict what will happen. It's also all
starting so early, potentially even ill advised
that it's starting so early in the sense that,
you know, Trump seemed to think it was better
for him legally to announce early. Even though
Merrick Garland of others have said it's
really not going to make a difference,
we're going to do what we have to do. But
these are the potential reasons that Trump
may struggle, the obstacles he may face.
And a lot of it is going to come down to,
does Ron DeSantis actually run for this thing? The
latest polling is unbelievable for Ron DeSantis.